when a bug tries to bite you you can
always swat it away unfortunately
most plants don't have that luxury what
they do have scientists have just
discovered is an innovative system of
communicating danger to their other
parts using some of the same signals as
and animal nervous systems researchers
have shown that plants can sense the
touch of a caterpillars tiny toes and
respond defensively scientists made this
discovery as they were investigating how
plant sends gravity they suspected
calcium signaling was involved so they
genetically engineered an Arab adopts
Asst to glow brighter whenever calcium
levels increased when they observe the
plant under a fluorescence microscope
they then realized that calcium was
dramatically increasing in response to
wounding so how do plants know to go on
guard it starts with a chemical an amino
acid called glutamate any type of
agitation from a bug bite to a
mechanical cut causes the release of
glutamate activating receptors that
trigger a calcium based signal that
moves through the plant the signal
travels the green highway of the plants
vascular system in just one to two
minutes activating defense hormones that
prepare distant leaves for an impending
invasion by gaining a better grasp of
this process
researchers can better monitor signaling
and somebody may be able to manipulate
plant communication so the next time you
brush up against a plant know that they
are feeling your every touch
[Music]